another Starbucks location in the valley
has unionized it is the third store in
Nevada to join the union that store
locate
locate reporter Brian will explains what
this means and how it could impact your
next cup of coffee
and enhances every single hot and cold
beverage since 2021 330 Starbucks stores
have unionized across the country it's
happening here in the valley there's
been a lack of employees on the floor
lack of hours there was just there
needed to be change overall and with the
Union becoming a union we would have
that change and those results that we
want for workers here at this North Las
Vegas Starbucks have voted
overwhelmingly for a union
24-2 the final tally the store joins two
others on the West Side rainbow and Oaky
and Tanea and Azure the workers say they
want better working conditions Fair
wages and more consistent schedules this
is a good thing for partners and not
only the partners but also our customers
because the way that our benefits are
going to get better we will also be able
to give them better service Starbucks is
pushing back in a statement sent to
eight news now it says in part we
respect the right of all Partners to
make their own decision decisions about
Union representation and we are
committed to engaging in good faith
collective bargaining for each store
where a union has been appropriately
certified Starbucks also says they have
proposed contract negotiations for the
two other locations but say Workers
United never confirmed dates or in one
case even responded Workers United claim
Starbucks has been stalling negotiations
and has committed violations of federal
labor law as for this store in North Las
Vegas we're waiting to get a contract
we're hoping that within a year we can
reach the negotiation and get a contract
for now you won't notice any changes at
the locations with a union but for
workers they will immediately have Union
representation in all matters with their
corporate owner now you can read the
full